[Music]
the joy of intimacy is the reward of
commitment
keep the first date short sweet and
simple and they'll come back to you
[Music]
to find a prince you gotta kiss a few
toads
[Music]
opposites attract
and then aggravate
dating requires a leap of faith that the
two of you can have a good time together
for an hour or two
[Music]
dating an ex is the equivalent of
failing a test you already had the
answers to
[Music]
dating has become a sport not about
finding the person you love
date someone because you see a future
with that person
not because you want to see if it would
work out
everyone knows that dating in your 30s
is not the happy-go-lucky free-for-all
it was when you were 22.
it's only later that you realize the
feeling of happiness you had with a man
didn't prove that you were in love with
him
your children are a reflection of your
resolute spirit and fierce affection
great love calls for great sacrifice
good-looking individuals are treated
better than homely ones in virtually
every social situation from dating to
trial by jury
the best place to be is surrounded by
people who love you
if there hadn't been women we'd still be
squatting in a cave eating raw meat
we made civilization in order to impress
our girlfriends
falling in love and having a
relationship are two different things
treasure your relationships not your
possessions
[Music]
dating has awkward moments when one
person wants more than the other
[Music]
a successful relationship requires a lot
of work and commitment
[Music]
if you're a sports fan you realize that
when you take a girl to a game she has
to root for your team
she doesn't have a choice
maybe the most you can expect from a
relationship that goes bad is to come
out of it with a few good songs
[Music]
however successful you are there is no
substitute for a close relationship
we all need them
[Music]
do not look at your boyfriend as just a
boyfriend
look at him as a friend
if your best friend has stolen your
girlfriend it becomes life and death
you show your vulnerability through
relationships and those feelings are a
soft spot
everyone needs to have a soft spot
[Music]
the magic in a relationship means not
judging others
[Music]
in a relationship you have to open
yourself up
[Music]
smart women love smart men more than
smart men love smart women
[Music]
assumptions are the termites of
relationships
you didn't date someone to change him
you dated him because you wanted him the
way he was
flaws fears and all
dating with no intent to marry is like
going to the grocery store with no money
you either leave unhappy or take
something that isn't yours
never let a fool kiss you or a kiss fool
you
you know when you're in love when you
can't fall asleep at night because
reality is better than your dreams
dating should be less about matching
outward circumstances than meaning inner
necessities
[Music]
a kiss is a lovely trick designed by
nature to stop speech when words become
superfluous
dating is something you do before making
binding choices or exclusive commitments
love doesn't make the world go round
love is what makes the ride worthwhile
[Music]
a person's readiness to date is largely
a matter of maturity and environment
[Music]
old-fashioned dating still exists
you're either dating the wrong people
or you are the problem
dating is a give and take
if you only see it as taking
you are not getting it
the most difficult part of dating is the
initial invitation
[Music]
dating is primarily a numbers game
you go through a lot of people to find a
good relationship
that's just the way it is
[Music]
workshops and seminars are basically
financial speed dating for clueless
people
[Music]
people tend to look at dating like going
on a safari
they're trying to land a trophy
[Music]
dating is where you pretend you're
someone you're not to impress someone
you don't know
a guy should make a woman he is dating
feel different and more important than
anyone else in his life
dating is an opportunity to practice how
to relate to other people
[Music]
men will sleep with women they wouldn't
date and women will date men they
wouldn't sleep with
don't look for a partner who is eye
candy
look for a partner who is soul food
don't date anyone you can't see yourself
marrying
[Music]
better to put your heart on the line
risk everything and walk away with
nothing
then play it safe
love is a lot of things but safe isn't
one of them
[Music]
[Music]
you